welcome everybody to what has been
mostly mostly sunny but rainy today
Martha's Vineyard I have so much to talk
about we'll talk a little bit about the
show break on the bonus show when Pat
joins me we're going to talk about
canceled culture later on today I do
have some segments planned about what's
going on with coronavirus cases versus
deaths which I got a bunch of emails
about over the weekend but to start with
we have to talk about this complete
softball propaganda interview that
Donald Trump was given on Fox News which
still managed to go completely and
horribly wrong and as you know one of
the themes of the presidency of Donald
Trump has been self-inflicted damage
because a ton of the stuff that has gone
wrong for Donald Trump has been
self-inflicted it's been because of his
own doing had he not been spouting off
on Twitter for example for months and
months and months the entire Russia
probe would likely have come and gone
with a lot less grief for Donald Trump
than than what ended up being and it's
very very much extended Fiasco had
Donald Trump simply avoided extraneous
belligerent statements about coronavirus
it's going to go away 15 cases will go
to 0 and if instead he focused on
building a testing program quickly that
worked we wouldn't be in the shape that
we're in right now I could give you more
examples but I think you get this idea
of self-inflicted damage from Donald
Trump Donald Trump went on Sean
Hannity's Fox News program and he was
given a complete softball propaganda
interview the crowd was filled with
sycophants
who felt bad for how tough things had
been for him
Hannity at this point you know he's a
friend of Donald Trump's he was seen
recently getting onto Donald Trump's
marine one helicopter in advance of
Trump getting on they went somewhere
together they regularly speak so that so
so Hannity interviewing Trump at this
point is very similar to like when Don
junior interviewed Donald Trump recently
it's the type of stuff you expect in
North Korea but the differences Trump is
so incompetent that even his son or his
friend Sean Hannity giving him the most
soft ball of softball interviews still
can't make him look good so let's get
into a Donald Trump is of course running
for re-election I've been saying for a
while now
there's been no coherent case made for
why people should vote for Donald Trump
other than Trump attacking Joe Biden
which he's been doing for a while so
Trump was teed up this easy question hey
what would your second term priorities
be what would you focus on in a second
term easy opportunity and Trump couldn't
name anything take a look at this if you
here in 131 days from now at some point
in the night or early morning we can now
project Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th President of the
United States let's talk how'd it what's
at stake in this election as you compare
and contrast and what is one of your top
priority items for a second term well
one of the things that will be really
great you know the word experience is
still good I always say talent is more
important than experience I've always
said that but the word experience is a
very important word it's an important
meeting I never did this before I never
slept over in Washington I was in
Washington I think 17 times all of a
sudden the president the United States
you know the story of riding down
Pennsylvania Avenue with our first lady
and I say this is great but I didn't
know very many people in Washington
wasn't my thing I was from Manhattan
from New York now I know everybody and I
have great people in the administration
you make some mistakes like you know an
idiot like Bolton all you want to do is
drop bombs on everybody you don't have
to drop bombs on everybody you have to
kill people you have John Bolton in fact
released classified material should he
be prosecuted yeah oh absolutely well he
did release classified actually this is
a so this is the softball of softballs
from Sean Hannity and Donald Trump just
can't answer it experience is important
I never slept over in DC I made a
mistake to hire John Bolton let's put
this on the screen and I won't do this
with all of the clips but to really
understand how ridiculous of a
non-answer this is to the question what
are your priorities let's actually look
at what Donald Trump said quote well one
of the things that will be really great
you know the word experience is still
good
I always say that talent is more
important than experience I've always
said that but the word experience is a
very important word it's a very
important meaning I never did this
before I never slept over in Washington
so you get the idea
so what would your priorities be Trump
can't name anything here is Donald Trump
asked what does he think are the
greatest accomplishments of his first
term again very easy question important
if you're arguing for people to vote for
you to have a second term you have to
demonstrate or at least argue that you
did something good
Trump is unable to list anything other
than an Obama policy from 2014 called
veterans Choice which we'll talk about
and the fact that Mitch McConnell forced
in some judges so here's the person
asking the question you'll see just the
complete gushing supporter of Trump the
question is something I'm calling ultra
cringe let's start there the audience
has some questions for the president
we're gonna start from Linda hi Linda
from Wausau Wisconsin thank you for
being here with us today say a lot of
presidents are windows right windows you
know I bought a lot of Wausau windows
over the years and you know it's I
shouldn't give him a free commercial but
they did a good job it's a great window
they are Wisconsin 11 up here thank you
it's Nora Senor Presidente
my Cuban background to it I have a
question for you I appreciate so much
what you have done for this country and
I know it's been tough what do you think
is your greatest accomplishment in your
eyes so a lot of people think it's the
fact that we will have I think before
I'm finished this term we'll have close
to 300 judges federal judges a lot of
people think because that's a record
that's a number that nobody can even
believe and part of it was that
President Obama was unable to get judges
approved in a large number about 142
judges so I took it off got them
approved and then got a lot of pro
Beyonc
be close to 302 Supreme Court judges
grade ones and so I think a lot of
people would say that so the judge stuff
understand it's not really Trump's doing
it's really Mitch McConnell's I've said
before Mitch McConnell has been one of
the most successful Republican operators
of the last many many years McConnell
blocked Barack Obama getting a Supreme
Court nominee held the seat open long
enough that Donald Trump was able to put
in Neel Gorsuch who of course was
recommended by somebody else to Donald
Trump so Trump says judges have been my
biggest accomplishment now it's true
that the people Trump picks are a
disaster but the reason they're getting
in is because of Mitch McConnell the
reason they're getting selected is
because conservative groups are telling
Trump pick from this list it's not even
really a Trump accomplishment but it is
a very good reason to vote for Joe Biden
first of all then here's the second part
of Trump's answer where he says my one
of my biggest accomplishments is
veterans Choice which was an Obama
policy from 2014 and we got veterans
Choice approved and veterans
accountability that's where you can fire
people that do a bad job you couldn't do
it before very hard to get they tried to
get it for 50 years because the civil
service unions essentially couldn't you
know get it I got it and the other thing
is veterans choice where if they can't
see a doctor we have great doctors in
the VA but if you can't see a doctor you
go out and you get a private doctor we
pay the bill and it's you have no idea
how great it's been so veterans
accountability is BS that's a Marco
Rubio bill from 2017 it's trash it's a
trash bill at least it did happen during
Trump's presidency the other policy
Trump mentions here veterans Choice
that's a 2014 Obama policy Trump made
some changes to it but understand that
what Trump is claiming to be his biggest
accomplishments are Mitch McConnell
getting judges confirmed and a 2014
Obama policy it's a comedy of
embarrassment also funny by the way that
his one accomplishment which is really
Obama's is one where the government
gives people health care Trump is right
now trying to further damage Obama care
to take away health care from 20 million
people and yet he cites as one of his
greatest accomplishments Trump says vote
for me again because of Obama's 2014
policy which I tweaked which gives free
healthcare through the government which
most of his supporters are actually
against inconceivable I mean just just a
laughable joke of an interview then
Donald Trump goes into what I call the
Sur routine the Sur routine is when
Trump retells a story of someone coming
to him and saying something and he
always he often says they came to me and
they said sir X Y Z right fill in the
blanks in this case it's they came to me
and black people said sir thank you for
calling out something I guess take a
look at this one it's a doozy
we have cities that are worse in some
cases far worse take a look at Detroit
take a look at what's happening in
Oakland take a look at what's happening
in Baltimore and everyone gets upset
when I say it they say oh is that a
racist statement it's not a racist
frankly black people come up to me say
thank you thank you sir for saying it
they want to help these cities it's like
living in hell right so black people are
coming to Trump asking him please sir
get us out of our hell like cities does
anybody believe that black people who
support Trump at 8% are coming to him
and thanking him for anything and now
this gets us to the climax of this
softball interview Trump again is
insisting if we didn't test for
coronavirus we wouldn't have any cases
and he goes into this thing of how there
are 19 different names for coronavirus
take a look thing if we didn't do
testing we'd have no cases other
countries they don't test minions so up
to almost 30 million tests so when you
do 30 men you're gonna have a kid with
the sniffles and they'll say it's
coronavirus whatever you want to call it
I said the other night there are so many
names to this I could name 19 names like
Corona 19 but I could name 19 names
right I mean listen if we didn't have
border patrol we would not find anybody
cross
the border illegally problem solved
right if we didn't ever test for STDs
you'd be totally clean right
no coronavirus testing means no cases
got it makes perfect sense repeating
this again and as I've said before he's
had an opportunity to get away from that
horrible answer he could frame this in
some other way but continuing to repeat
that bogus framing and then here is the
de naman
so this is not the climax of the
interview this is the de Newmont because
it's almost like a sad finale here is
Trump almost sounding resigned to the
idea that he's going to lose in November
to Joe Biden he's talking like he's
already lost listen to this here's a guy
doesn't talk nobody hears and whatever
he does talk he can't put two sentences
together I don't want to be nice or uh
nice okay but I mean the man can't speak
and he's going to be your president
because some people don't love me maybe
and you know all I'm doing is doing my
job don't forget before the China plague
came in and said China plague before
that came in we had the best job numbers
we've ever had we had the best economy
we've ever had Joe Biden is going to be
your president because some people don't
love me maybe it's all about Trump it's
never about you destroyed trade it's
never about you bungled coronavirus it's
never about you made us the laughing
stock of the world it's some people
don't love me so they're going to vote
for Joe Biden famous last words by the
way we can hope but we've got to get out
and vote so imagine a complete softball
propaganda interview meant to make Trump
look good that's all and Trump couldn't
do it in any way that made sense he
misses the Gimme as we say in golf which
Donald Trump knows very very much about
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way to take control of your
health and get personalized care from
the comfort of your home it's a service
called steady MD they're one of our
sponsors you
take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician who
understands your health needs you have a
one-hour video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call each doctor at steady MD
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you you
get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about health
concerns send prescriptions to your home
or local pharmacy and anything they
can't do online they'll quickly set you
up with an in-person provider to do
things like blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays there are so many practical
advantages to using steady MD for
primary care and it's also so much more
affordable go to steady MD comm slash
Pakman to take the free quiz see which
doctor is right for you I took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor who
specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started just click the
link right underneath this video